insofern nicht sondern ich bin so ein
dummer spaß bongo bongo ramba zamba zum
mit max hey was geht ab schuss kann er
machen kann also bomba pinguinen
bomberman falls sie die erste folge was
fährst folge falls ihr das andere video
was wir von schon mal gemacht und ich
gesehen haben sucht einfach das sucht
einfach bomberman von crafter dann seht
ihr ja schon das war richtig witzig
zeigen ausgedacht wie spät es normal das
ist ein anderer server weise sieht genau
gleich aus
seit dem erscheinen gleich ihr das jetzt
überall und unter anderem namen
wenn man ihr das video gerade seht ist
kt vierter achter also das ist in drei
wochen vor uns weil wir halt am
vorproduziert sind aber es sollte alles
passen kommen und ich würde sagen 32
also müssen halt ihr diese bomben
erstmal damit die anteile bevor ab erst
mal kurz erklärung von craft es ist rot
und ich bin gelb genau das was ist das
die rede ist halt dass man sich
gegenseitig in die luft jagt und man
kann wenn man diese blauen eislöffel in
die luft jagt power up sein sondern
da wird man sich ausgemacht ja das ist
echt krass laune bei mir ich muss kein
bisschen leiser gemacht einfach
also es gibt dann dinge wie
beispielsweise max ethikrat schon oben
links selbst relativ schnell
ich habe relativ großen bomben radius
dass sie die komplette doch keine zwei
bomben setzt das fakt mich ein bisschen
ab und ich bin auch noch nicht schnell
und am ende jetzt kann ich drei bomben
sogar setzen
am besten schauen jetzt auch das pop
doch nicht kaputt collect ist auch so
ein bisschen bei dir sein alter nicht
einmal halter aber das klappt nicht
alter juliane bitte sein glück haben und
die schwestern
wie bei diesen teams ist das nur in
dieser harnisch alter alter jan alston
heißt ja auch bauch oder arman mein gott
oh mein gott du kannst mich richtig
festen ich hab es lag an mir wie ein
stück dreck woche ist er heute man
richtige das hätte ich nie gedacht als
er ist also wir haben gesagt wir spielen
drei runden bis auf 3 damit richten
gewinner haben werden wahrscheinlich in
der region nicht so lange werden wie die
ihr schickt einfach in meine richtung
wir sind richtig gut
wer richtig gute drin geworden otto
fischer gut geworden
camatte will man erst mal noch mal spiel
nochmals beispiel und sich sogar ich bin
jetzt geld um jetzt bin ich nämlich geld
sich gerade selbst eine bombe bestellt
also längst auch ein bisschen irgendwie
bei mir fast nicht mehr noch microsoft
office
ja allerdings daran also ich weiß auch
nicht mehr dadurch nicht liegen endlich
beenden als anderen einmal bisher sollte
es eigentlich schaffen bleibt ein
bisschen länger aufkam besten ja noch so
zwei minuten damit bei dir diesem jahr
gar keine gallen sachen jetzt da nix
wieder nix ich hab noch keine geile
sachen bekommen jetzt hab ich halt drei
sachen dürfen nur füße wenn ich was
heißt das eigentlich also das heißt
bomben fertig ja genau weißt du wenn du
mehrere von diesen bomben weg teil hast
du hast bomben
du bist behinderte max hat heute echt
sein
seinen rapper tag irgendwie herrsche
also ich wollte noch gewerkelt
wie man mit image zu zerstören ich habe
dort mein image zerstört oder eben mit
zerstörte aber das massaker an
allerdings walter borst das geil
wo ist das geld hermann richter
ich hab ich nicht gesehen noch mal zwei
junge frau direkt komplett aus alter wir
uns einfach immer gegenseitig blockieren
das hätte genauso wie vorhin wieder
richtig krass ist wieder so ein
deathmatch als zwei junge das quasi
schon gewonnen jetzt um man das nur
wieder ihren runde jetzt letzte spiel du
musst bisschen lauter reden für die
herrenrunde danke ja nicht übersteuern
ich verwöhne folgen beim micro mit mixa
besser hören kannst ganz auch wirklich
mal das total verpennt die ganze zeit
dass man ja so ein faden hat an der
bombe explodiert weil wir nicht gesehen
aber die sache ist die wenn man eine
andere bombe da hat die sache ist die
wie das einfach wieder niemand versteht
unsere hilfe wir fahren jedes jahr hin
und
bitte mach sollte jetzt mal als oma
klären ob ich glaube rhein hin dass wir
fünf erhöhen wie dann haben wir schon
wir machen auf 4 wenn du jetzt das
gewinnst dann ist halt vorbei und dann
echt das gerinne oder so entschieden
sich auch nicht so lange halten weil die
ganzen letzten videos die schon
aufgenommen sind so 20 minuten und alles
natürlich finden so ein dummer spaß
laufen und mein gott das habe ich
mitbekommen ich gucken auf einmal kann
ich nie mehr lauf ich denke oh mein gott
okay vom entscheiden jetzt müssen wir
zusammen gefahren wir fahren regelmäßig
nach zolder richtig jährlich und
vielleicht noch an falls ein paar leute
mich auch kennen wir haben uns ja auch
kennengelernt und da habe ich auch
beziehungsweise ein paar tage später als
wir von sie zurückkam habe ich mit mit
luca beschlossen einkommen nicht muss
sie noch auf sylt waren haben wir bei
dir in der butze gechillt
ja wenn ich im haus sondern in seiner
kleinen wohnung wenn ich total dürfen
mieter und wir wollten bei dem grillen
und das war mussten wir irgendwie so
durchringen wochen der region und her
aber nicht meter nein nicht erfasst ich
habe gewonnen
ich habe gewonnen nur weil du noch zwei
runden machen wollte meine meine ersten
runden waren übelsten wird ihm das auf
jeden fall schon seit längerem dahin und
wir haben uns mal kennen lernen wir
kennen uns da komplett aus
ihr werdet wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
von der stadt sehen aber halt mehr so
wenn wir irgendwo am strand sind oder
bei irgendwem chillen oder mehr sind
aber nicht so wenn wir die stadt laufen
weil ich finde sich wenn man so eine
kamera vor sicher trägt das habe ich
schon in hamburg gemacht hat jeder blöd
angeguckt war ein bisschen komisch jetzt
oder wenn ich muss immer zu denken
dieses video kommt am 4 acht raus und
ich sage in diesem video ich werde max
besuchen und das video
wo ich mag besucht habe kam einfach
schon vor zwei wochen in dem moment
gerade das ist schon irgendwie krass
deswegen ich mache das für euch das
ganze produzieren damit ihre videos
haben wir nicht im urlaub bin und ich
freue mich voll dass alles klappt das
habe ich schon bei facebook in facebook
post geschrieben dass ich das richtig
cool finde dass das alles so gut klappt
gerade mit frau produzieren wenn man
sich in den letzten sommerurlaub
erinnert dann weil das interesse an
andere alle drei tage mein kleines video
da sagen wir unrecht und die leute haben
so haben zugeschrieben ich weiß nicht
auf heute über aufträgt so haben die
leute so die gerüchteküche alter in den
kommentaren zu lukas vom autounfall
gestorben diesen komplett ausgelastet da
so gar keinen sinn diese macht man sowas
nicht als irgendwann mal kein video
kommt du kannst nicht in form autounfall
gestorben man hat schnell ich einfach
wirklich und dann alles anders
ich war gut autounfall ihr auf holz
klopfen dann egal ich würde sagen da
rein und da schwarz pink und ben bongo
gefallen hat lassen meint da ihr findet
diesmal den link in der beschreibung
damit wir den link auch wiederfinden
stunden haben wir gesucht
stimmen die mit losen das war heftig
egal ob fünf tränen geweint
sarah im auge